one of the interesting things about
music that touches our soul music that
induces melancholy perhaps a bit of
sadness is the question why would we do
that to ourselves right
why wouldn't we listen to a song that
makes us cry what kind of sick pleasure
do we get from nostalgia right and it
was an interesting article in brain
pickings that says that this is part of
the purpose of beautiful music and that
music makes room for our pain and by
actually making room for our pain acts
as a cathartic experience that allows us
to release pent-up emotions that
otherwise would drive us into a neurotic
spiral into hell
in other words music is therapeutic
melancholic music beautiful music that
makes you cry is piercing you in a
certain way and making room for your
pain
why because we're all full of pain
that's the thing that we tend to forget
most of us are just generally very good
at repressing it repressing the grim
reality of our condition but most of us
we've we picked up so much pain along
the way we're all suffering from a kind
of psychological PTSD it's called being
alive you know it's called falling in
love and having your heart broken it's
called failing in life and getting back
up again but those failings they eat at
us so we carry this pain and we need
outlets for okay
and some of us become artists
become painters and some of us become
lyricist and some of us build companies
that change the world and plant the flag
on the surface of the Moon but for
others of us sometimes what it takes is
a beautiful song that lets us cry that
lets us make room for our pain so that
we may dissipate it move
you